hello there reject nation
I'm Greg Alba and I'm John Humphrey
we're gonna watch this another endgame
spot which I'm sure will reveal close to
nothing new but maybe I will be
surprised
maybe the comment section is rife with
yeah because it is two and a half
minutes so I don't know it has to be
something cool here to offer before we
hop into this there's a couple things I
wanted to mention really quick that I
hope you don't skip to the reaction for
I just did an interview with
oscar-winning makeup effects artist Joel
Harlow who's actually worked did the
main makeup for several o'clock with
movies including this year's Hellboy
black panther Logan so keep a lookout
for that and the other thing is keep a
lookout for Avengers end game review
there is an opening sketch that will be
there and don't worry it is not five
minutes long all right it's six longer
yeah and we made sure to meet it halfway
trim it down
[Music]
Captain America Missy
I see a bunch of a-holes
[Music]
[Applause]
is changing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we're the ball
[Music]
my nipples are so hard
[Applause]
great transition
[Applause]
[Music]
the first one right there I'd removed
with the revenge whoever takes
[Music]
I hope that they just keep saying that
to reach that overhead
[Music]
such a cool shot
weirdly thus far I think that is my
favorite preview shot of in-game is the
three of them the backs their legs
walking into the wreckage yeah yeah
whatever reason it gets me hype kids say
that was really cool we like we really
like watching any of these tribute
compilations they put together I just
had a youtubers put together the first
you need a freaking ultimate one from
Disney more i sat here wondering to
myself did some kid like distinguish
themselves in the game of just YouTube
compilations Supercuts and then get a
job at Marvel to make the Kulin cuz I
don't know I thought they chose some
really good moments out of so many
movies and I love the way that they
start out with all the narrations about
like the symbol that each of the main
three characters stands for and then
what the group as a whole is you know
yeah when they first started naming all
the titles I was like flash 20 odd names
up on screen cuz also to you know half
of them are the same name just with the
suffix or a number you know whatever I
really like the marketing for this how
they advertise like especially an
advertisement like this yeah makes it
feel like endgame is some life finite
ending yet to this franchise when it's
obviously not we know of other films
that are coming after endgame yeah and
other characters will be back but in a
lot of ways it is teasing the end of
least one the finite ending to one of
these characters right yeah I guess my
greatest hope for any game is that it is
the end of something tonal or stylistic
or you know just spiritual even for
Marvel so that you know whatever comes
after that whatever starts the new phase
aside from Sony Marvel's spider-man far
from home you know whatever that is has
a new flavor has a new kind of aura
about it or something like I don't know
you know we can do to find out for sure
is we can just go online apparel we can
right now and just spoil it for
ourselves in the comments I am going to
be deactivating my social media
until we go to our press reading we are
going to be shutting off the power in
this apartment yeah we are not going to
be uploading videos we will not be using
like idea of any kind already in the
Game of Thrones video the second one we
put up just yesterday I did say I'm not
gonna rename or the comments on like the
Game of Thrones videos at least no
reading comments yes I mean whatever
comments you want right now so we have
seen endgame you're not gonna read
anything spoiled by looking at a video
completely unrelated and people just
like you know cuz I don't I don't know
what happens in the end game I already
muted so many words and hashtags on
Twitter case I have to go on there cuz
some people who message me directly so
there's a lot of muted words that way
they just don't appear my feet but still
you know someone could easily just be
like Tony Stark's then not saying I
don't know but it could easily say that
in some other video be like you son of a
[ __ ] cuz even if that's not true it'll
be my head and I'll be like and then if
it happens I'll be like yeah yeah
exactly it just messes without my whole
viewing experience
yeah it just paints over with a giant
question mark of is that info gonna be
true yeah I'm loving Iron Man's new suit
though that we're seeing in this trailer
it means like really darkly lit in this
specific image but you know the other
trailer it's clear but like the yellow
erotic kind of flashy tacticals
yeah yeah it does feel very metallic
makes sense he's Iron Man feel free to
correct me if I'm wrong seen Finity war
3 times I don't remember like the wings
that are appearing outside of Google I'm
scared to Google I'm scared to go right
now
yeah I mean I feel like yeah we've seen
things like this that's not another
mounts and it has had
I remember seeing a toy advertisement
when infinity war was coming out for
this suit I can't recall this one as if
that item is specifically in infinity
war or if I'm even thinking about like
the iron spider Zoomer he's got the legs
and stuff like that and getting confused
with that or whatever but even either
way this is boring chunk um as you know
anything looks new and the colors scheme
of his whole outfit is awesome yeah you
know I like the dark gold
that's a big USC fan you just got those
gold and dark red colors and I thought
this was cool of you know the Guardians
obviously they're making it part three
so yeah at least some of them are coming
back James Gunn's vacuum and far from
home and it was so cool to because I
could have just done the characters that
we know for sure are gonna be the
primary focus in this movie without an
end game you know just the main Avengers
characters ant-man yeah but it's cool
that they still included like black
panther spider-man Doctor Strange all
these other characters that we probably
will be brought back by the end of this
movie yeah but we're not gonna be in
this movie for most of it so yeah that
was so cool to have them on that's what
I mean they're really doing a great job
of teasing something that could be
potentially be finitely well you know
and they're giving me a the cool thing
is because infinity were so jam-packed
with people it feels like endgame is
going to be focused on just arc or trip
and that's really coming to life for me
well guys as you can see with all the
boxes in the background we are moving
out and I got to be out everybody in the
Masons turn into crazy crazy busy month
so there's a lot more one takes more
than ever right now because it's just so
damn busy lately before we wrap this
video up I'd like to say thank you to
everyone who has followed us on our
patreon page over there we do weekly Q&A
is TV show reactions stream along some
whether a reaction highlights included
for several shows and also a music video
coverage with that in mind let's give a
patient the day shout out to a man named
Raj Krishnan Niraj lives in New Jersey
and he recently quit his job thank God
that did not affect his pledge you know
what I mean thank God setting gotta keep
that pledge I'll support your region
even if you're unemployed man yeah woo
thank God but he's looking for a new
place to live he's thinking of moving
out of New Jersey starting up his own
business which i think is a great
exciting opportunity just so you know
98% of people who start up businesses
succeed so you have yeah an easy shot at
this man take all your money and sink it
right in I hope you moved to California
we can do some greens together and maybe
it'll spark a new thought or D motivate
you
either way we are pushing you in a
direction I love you Niraj I wish you
best of luck on your two percent failure
chance of you know the joke subscribe to
the reject nation click that
notification bell keep a lookout for
endgame review and that interview with
Joel Harlow that's his name of the
beginning I don't know it was a long
interview